This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm sitting in a tiny little room with this microphone right up to my mouth so that the sound of my voice is transmitted directly from me to you. There's no sense of the room that I'm in. When I stop speaking, the sound stops. There's no reverberation, no reverb. Roman and I are both talking in rooms outfitted specially for recording. verb. Roman and I are both talking in rooms outfitted, especially for recording. Rooms, that sound good. That's producer Avery Truffleman. Because if I step outside this tiny, completely padded studio, okay, it's still quiet because I'm inside, but I'm gonna walk around a little bit so you can hear the architecture around me. You can tell now that I'm in a bathroom, or you can tell if I enter the stairwell outside our office.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我现在正坐在一个狭小的房间里，麦克风就贴在嘴边，这样我的声音就能直接从我传送到你们那里。这里完全听不出我所在的房间有任何空间感。当我停止说话时，声音就戛然而止。没有回音，没有混响。罗曼和我都在专门为录音打造的房间里说话。动词。罗曼和我都在专门为录音打造的房间里说话。听起来不错的房间。那是制作人埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）。因为如果我走出这个狭小、完全做过隔音处理的小录音棚——好吧，里面还是很安静，因为我在里面——但我要四处走走，好让你们听到我周围的建筑声音。你们现在能听出来我在浴室里，或者也能听出我是否进入了我们办公室外面的楼梯间。
And if you're not listening in headphones, my voice is bouncing around your car or whatever room you're in. Whatever you're hearing, sound is affected by the architecture. There are two main ways to control the sound in a building. Active acoustics and passive acoustics. Passive acoustics are the materials in a space, like the padding in the studio room. Carpeting and drapes are also
如果你没有戴耳机听，我的声音就会在你的车里或你所在的任何房间里回荡。无论你听到的是什么，声音都会受到建筑结构的影响。控制建筑物内声音的方法主要有两种：主动声学和被动声学。被动声学是指空间中的材料，比如录音棚房间里的吸音棉。地毯和窗帘也是
absorptive materials that soak up sound. Glass and porcelain, on the other hand, create more reverb. Essentially, if it's shiny, it's going to be reflective. It is an easy way to interpret that. This is Ashley Hansen. My name is Ashley Hansen. I'm the Design Services Manager at Myersound. Myersound is a company that mostly makes active acoustics,
能吸收声音的吸音材料。另一方面，玻璃和瓷砖会产生更多的混响。从本质上讲，如果表面光亮，它就会反射声音。这是一种很容易理解的解释。这是阿什利·汉森（Ashley Hansen）。我叫阿什利·汉森。我是梅尔声学（Meyer Sound）的设计服务经理。梅尔声学是一家主要制造主动声学设备的 公司，
which is to say speakers, amplifiers, and other electric sound equipment. People probably have run into our products. They just don't know that it's mire sound. Mire sound makes a lot of the big speakers hanging off of the ceilings at concerts and Broadway shows. But their products are also in a lot of unexpected places. Crew ships, restaurants, we are in some corporate headquarters, educational facilities, airports. Over 600 Myr sound speakers were used
也就是扬声器、放大器和其他电子音响设备。人们可能都遇到过我们的产品。他们只是不知道那是梅尔声学的。梅尔声学制造了许多悬挂在音乐会和百老汇演出天花板上的大型扬声器。但他们的产品也出现在许多意想不到的地方。游轮、餐馆，我们在一些公司总部、教育机构、机场。使用了600多个梅尔声学扬声器
when the Pope spoke in Mexico. One of the things I tell people in general is, if we're doing a job right, you might never notice that we're even there. And that's part of Ashley's job at Myr Sound. To make sure the sound equipment is effortlessly integrated into a building using both passive and active acoustics, materials and electronics. But often in architecture,
当教皇在墨西哥演讲时。我常对人们说的一点是，如果我们把工作做好了，你可能根本不会注意到我们的存在。这也是阿什利在梅尔声学工作的一部分。确保音响设备通过结合被动和主动声学、材料和电子技术，毫不费力地融入建筑物中。但通常在建筑中，
what looks the best is at odds with what sounds the best. Of course you don't necessarily want to always see the big black speakers somewhere, and so we have to get creative. We like our speakers out of sight. And we also like high ceilings and long glass windows, which make spaces sound really reverberant. So architecture is a puzzle for Ashley and her team to solve. Whenever we see rooms that have curved walls, we kind of cringe, especially if they're out of glass. Oh, that's pretty. When we approach spaces, there are things that, we kind of cringe, especially if they're out of glass. Oh, that's pretty.
看起来最好的效果往往与听起来最好的效果相冲突。当然，你不一定总是希望在某个地方看到巨大的黑色扬声器，所以我们必须发挥创意。我们喜欢把扬声器隐藏起来。我们还喜欢高天花板和长长的玻璃窗，这会让空间听起来有很强的混响。因此，建筑对阿什利和她的团队来说是一个需要解开的谜题。每当我们看到有弧形墙壁的房间时，我们都会感到有点不寒而栗，尤其是当它们是玻璃材质的时候。哦，那挺好看的。当我们接近空间时，有些东西……我们有点不寒而栗，尤其是当它们是玻璃材质的时候。哦，那挺好看的。
When we approach spaces, there are things that, although they're beautiful, we know are going to definitely put pressure on us to come up with creative and unique ways to appease the visual and sonic needs of the room. So it depends on what you're trying to do in that space. If it's a venue for the symphony or the opera, you want the sound to be big and resonant and echoing. For a cafe or a place with acoustic performances, a little reverb is nice. But if you're trying to hear a lecture or a reading or say, have a meeting, you probably don't want much reverb at all. But we haven't always been able to precisely control the acoustics of a building. Sound,
当我们接近空间时，有些东西虽然很美，但我们知道这肯定会给我们带来压力，必须想出创造性和独特的方法来满足该房间视觉和声学的需求。所以这取决于你想在这个空间里做什么。如果这是一个交响乐或歌剧的演出场地，你会希望声音宏大、饱满且带有回响。对于咖啡馆或有声学表演的地方，有一点混响是很好的。但如果你是想听讲座、朗诵，或者是开会，你可能根本不希望有太多混响。但我们并非一直能够精确控制建筑物的声学效果。声音，
until fairly recently, was a somewhat mysterious element in architecture. In the late 18th century, there are all sorts of different theories about how to get good sound, but half of them contradict the other half, and no one really knew what to do. This is Emily Thompson. She's a history professor at half, and no one really knew what to do. This is Emily Thompson. She's a history professor at Princeton, and a scholar of sound technology. And she says, at the turn of the 20th century,
直到不久前，在建筑学中还是一个有点神秘的元素。在18世纪末，关于如何获得好声音有各种各样的理论，但其中一半的理论与另一半相矛盾，没有人真正知道该怎么做。这是埃米莉·汤普森（Emily Thompson）。她是普林斯顿大学的历史教授，也是声学技术学者。她说，在20世纪之交，
architectural acoustics are pretty much a role of the dice. Architects begin to fret that they don't really know what they're doing with this aspect of their designs, and it was all kind of left to chance. And if you were lucky, your theater would sound good. And it was all kind of left to chance. And if you were lucky, your theater would sound good. And if you were unlucky, it wouldn't.
建筑声学几乎完全靠碰运气。建筑师开始担心他们根本不知道自己在设计的这一方面在做什么，一切都有点听天由命。如果你运气好，你的剧院听起来就会很好。一切都有点听天由命。如果你运气好，你的剧院听起来就会很好。如果你运气不好，就不会好。
And in 1895, Harvard University was very unlucky. The university had just completed building the Fogg Art Museum. And it had a lecture hall where there was so much reverberation that they simply could not hold classes in that room. You couldn't understand this feature because there was so much reverberation that they simply could not hold classes in that room. You couldn't understand this feature because there was so much. The room was very confusion.
而在1895年，哈佛大学非常倒霉。该大学刚刚建成了福格艺术博物馆（Fogg Art Museum）。那里有一个演讲厅，回声大得根本无法在那里举行课程。你无法理解这个特征，因为回声太大了，以至于他们根本无法在那间教室里上课。你无法理解这个特征，因为回声太大了。这个房间非常混乱。
Harvard had just wasted a lot of money on a completely useless room. Sound had ruined it. And in an attempt to save the space, they listed the help of a rookie physics professor who had some time on his hands. So the president of Harvard asked this young physics professor to figure out how to fix that auditorium and make it usable teaching space. This professor's name was Wallace Sabine. And through this task, Sabine would eventually become the father of architectural acoustics.
哈佛在这样一个完全无用的房间上白白浪费了大量资金。声音把它给毁了。为了挽救这个空间，他们寻求了一位有一点空闲时间的物理系新人的帮助。于是哈佛校长请这位年轻的物理学教授想办法修复那个礼堂，使其成为一个可用的教学空间。这位教授名叫华莱士·萨宾（Wallace Sabine）。通过这项任务，萨宾最终成为了建筑声学之父。
This sent Wallace Sabine onto an investigative path that actually took several years collecting data. Basically making sounds in rooms and timing the reverb. He would take measurements of the different reverberation times in different rooms all over campus, and in order to do this under the quietest possible circumstances, he tended to run his experiments in the middle of the night. And he would change the reverberation time within a given room by bringing into it various sound absorbing materials. Sabine was a perfectionist. He threw out over 3,000 measurements after determining that his own clothes had a small effect upon the sound of the room. He started all over again, taking measurements in the dead of night, but now wearing the
这让华莱士·萨宾踏上了一条实际上花了数年时间收集数据的调查之路。基本上就是在房间里发出声音并计时混响。他会在校园各处的不同房间里测量不同的混响时间，为了在尽可能安静的环境下做到这一点，他往往在半夜进行实验。他会通过把各种吸音材料带进一个特定的房间来改变该房间的混响时间。萨宾是个完美主义者。在确定他自己的衣服对房间的声音产生了一点影响后，他抛弃了3000多次测量结果。他重新开始，在深夜进行测量，但现在每次都穿着
exact same outfit every time. Meanwhile the President of Harvard is waiting and waiting for this lecture hall to be made useful again. At one point, he finally says to the young professor, it's time for you to tell us what to do here. Enough is enough. And that night, feeling nervous under pressure, Sabine pours over his notebooks and has a breakthrough.
完全相同的衣服。与此同时，哈佛校长一直在等待、等待这个演讲厅重新变得有用。有一刻，他终于对这位年轻的教授说：“是时候告诉我们该怎么做了。够了。”那天晚上，在压力下感到紧张的萨宾翻阅着他的笔记本，迎来了突破。
Looking at all his measurements, he starts to notice a trend, a mathematical relationship between the size and materials of a room in its reverberation time. A relationship so steady that you can make a formula out of it. He discovers a mathematical formula that connects the architectural materials of the room and the behavior of sound within it. And this is a formula known as Sabine's formula now that really enables people to be able to predict the reverberation time of a room based on its design. Sabine's equation allowed for planning. Suddenly you could manipulate the reverb of a space by changing the materials the room was made of.
看着他所有的测量结果，他开始注意到一种趋势，即房间的尺寸和材料与其混响时间之间存在数学关系。这种关系如此稳定，以至于你可以从中制定出一个公式。他发现了一个数学公式，将房间的建筑材料与声音在其中的行为联系起来。这就是现在被称为萨宾公式的公式，它真正使人们能够根据房间的设计预测其混响时间。萨宾的方程式允许进行规划。突然之间，你可以通过改变房间的建造材料来操纵空间的混响。
So that then you can take any sort of architectural plan, you know, the dimensions, you know, how many square feet of plaster or wood or glass or upholstered seats, fill this room, and you can just kind of plug and chug, and the formula will turn out a predicted number for the reverberation time of the room. Sabine's formula helped architects design for as little or as much reverb as they wanted. Architects could now control the sound of a space. They could make big rooms with very little reverb. And so they begin to do just that. And the most remarkable early example of this was St. Thomas Church. St. Thomas Church, which is in New York City,
这样你就可以采用任何类型的建筑图纸，你知道尺寸，你知道这个房间里填满了多少平方英尺的灰泥、木材、玻璃或软垫座椅，然后你就可以直接代入计算，这个公式就会算出一个预测的房间混响时间数值。萨宾的公式帮助建筑师根据需要设计尽可能少或尽可能多的混响。建筑师现在可以控制空间的声音了。他们可以建造混响极小的巨大房间。于是他们开始着手这样做。其中最早、最引人注目的例子就是圣托马斯教堂（St. Thomas Church）。圣托马斯教堂位于纽约市，
not far from the Museum of Modern Art. The architects of this church wanted to build it in a neo-gothic style, basically to make it look like a European cathedral, made of stone with high sea leans and stained glass windows. But while they wanted this building to look Gothic, they realized that a Gothic sound would not work for a modern Protestant service.
离现代艺术博物馆不远。这座教堂的建筑师希望以新哥特式风格建造它，基本上让它看起来像一个欧洲大教堂，由石头建造，配有高高的天花板和彩色玻璃窗。但是，虽然他们希望这座建筑看起来具有哥特式风格，但他们意识到哥特式的声音并不适合现代的新教礼拜。
They wanted to hold a much more sermon-focused service, not just a medieval mass. It needed less reverb so parishioners could understand the words. So the architects turned to Wallace Sabine to make a sacred space that would be clear, calming, and reverb free. Sure, Wallace Sabine could add felts
他们希望举行一场更专注于布道的礼拜仪式，而不仅仅是中世纪弥撒。它需要更少的混响，这样教区居民才能听懂歌词。于是建筑师求助于华莱士·萨宾，以打造一个清晰、平静且没有混响的神圣空间。当然，华莱士·萨宾可以在建筑物中添加毛毡
and padding to the building, but he thought that didn't fit the feeling of a church. He worked with a tile maker to come up with special sound-absorbed of ceramic tiles with porous surfaces. He called them Rumpford Tiles. Rumpford Tile, they named it after a physicist who had kind of been interested in solving practical problems, and it's a substantial architectural material. It's not a matter of
和软垫，但他认为这不符合教堂的感觉。他与一家瓷砖制造商合作，设计出具有多孔表面的特殊吸音陶瓷砖。他称它们为鲁姆福德瓷砖（Rumford Tiles）。鲁姆福德瓷砖，他们用一位一直对解决实际问题感兴趣的物理学家的名字来命名它，这是一种实质性的建筑材料。这不仅仅是
just hanging drapes or tacking felt onto a surface. It's much more integral. So with St. Thomas Church, by using these sound absorbing tiles way up in all the ceiling vaults, they had the Gothic look without the Gothic sound. St. Thomas Church was completed in 1913. It's definitely not modern looking, but it was a landmark modern sounding building, completely engineered and formulated for environmental control. Thanks to the Rumford tile.
挂上窗帘或将毛毡钉在表面上。它要深刻得多。因此，对于圣托马斯教堂来说，通过在所有天花板拱顶高处使用这些吸音瓷砖，他们拥有了哥特式的外观，却没有哥特式的声音。圣托马斯教堂于1913年完工。它绝对看起来不现代，但它是一座具有里程碑意义的现代声音建筑，完全为环境控制进行了工程设计和配方设计。多亏了鲁姆福德瓷砖。
Sabine worked in public and private spaces all along the East Coast and came out with more products to accompany the Rumford tile. And he passed away in 1919, right really at a moment when a much more pervasive interest in controlling environmental sound would come to the fore. The roaring 20s. It got that name for a reason. It may very well be the case that it was louder in the 20s than now.
萨宾在整个东海岸的公共和私人空间工作，并推出了更多伴随鲁姆福德瓷砖的产品。他在1919年去世，正值人们对控制环境声音的普遍兴趣即将走到台前的一刻。咆哮的二十年代（The roaring 20s）。这个名字的由来是有原因的。20年代的声音很可能比现在还要大。
This was in era when cars and trucks did not uniformly come with mufflers. There were these new unfamiliar, unprecedentedly loud sounds of cars, of trains, of industrial machinery, of construction, of skyscrapers rising everywhere, and in the crowded city an escape was hard to find. An escape was hard to find. Sound crispness and clarity could provide calm and control. It meant a complete mastery of the environment. And so the desire to control sound within interior spaces is in part a kind of a drive to create refuge from the noisy tumult of the world outside.
这是一个汽车和卡车并非都统一安装消音器的时代。出现了这些新的、不熟悉的、前所未有 loud 的汽车声、火车声、工业机械声、建筑声、到处拔地而起的摩天大楼声，在拥挤的城市里很难找到逃离的地方。很难找到逃离的地方。声音的清脆和清晰可以提供平静和控制。这意味着对环境的完全掌控。因此，控制室内空间声音的欲望，部分原因是一种创造避难所的驱动力，以摆脱外部世界喧嚣的骚动。
Rumford tile launched an industry. By the 1930s, dozens of different corporations were manufacturing and selling vast quantities of acoustic building materials, with names like Acoustolith, Acousticello-Tex, and Sabonite. For those who could afford it, you know, whether you could buy a soundproofed apartment or just enjoy quiet offices or theaters. Quiet became a luxury commodity. Acoustic materials were so advanced that Sabon's formula couldn't apply anymore.
鲁姆福德瓷砖催生了一个行业。到20世纪30年代，数十家不同的公司在制造和销售大量声学建筑材料，名字如Acoustolith、Acousticello-Tex和Sabonite。对于那些买得起的人来说，你知道的，无论你是能买得起隔音公寓，还是只是享受安静的办公室或剧院。安静成了一种奢侈品。声学材料太先进了，以至于萨宾的公式不再适用了。
By 1930, you're really able to create spaces that simply didn't exist in the 19th century. Sabine's equation doesn't work particularly well. It was a product of the world in which he did his investigation, which was still that 19th century world filled with glass and wood and plaster. All this new acoustic technology was able to create a level of silence unprecedented in Sabine's time. Finally, it was quiet. Too quiet. But as the 20th century went on, people became disenchanted with the idea of completely
到1930年代，你确实能够创造出19世纪完全不存在的空间。萨宾的方程式并不是特别管用。它是他进行调查的那个世界的产品，那个世界仍然是充满玻璃、木材和石膏的19世纪世界。所有这些新型声学技术都能够创造出萨宾时代前所未有的安静水平。终于安静了。太安静了。但随着20世纪的推移，人们对声学效果完全减弱的封闭空间的理念开始感到失望。他们想让空气、光线和声音进来。有趣的是，到了20世纪70年代，人们在声学设计方面的一些文化因素和审美偏好自20世纪初以来已经发生了变化。在其中一些空间中，包括圣托马斯教堂，他们实际上决定他们想要的混响比这种材料所产生的要多。
closed off spaces with dampened acoustics. They wanted to let in air, light, and sound. Interestingly, by the 1970s, some of the cultural factors and the aesthetic preferences of people with respect to sound design had changed since the early 20th century. And in some of these spaces, including St. Thomas Church, they actually decided they wanted more reverberation than this material engendered.
因此在某些情况下，鲁姆福德瓷砖的多孔表面被重新涂上了油漆，以某种方式封住那些孔隙，使其更能反射声音。而如今，我们希望我们的建筑拥有一定范围的混响。现在，一个单一的房间或场地可以容纳许多不同种类的声音。这是可能的，不仅可以使用萨宾首创的那种被动声学材料，还可以使用主动声学。萨宾首创的材料，还有主动声学。使用麦克风、扬声器和数字信号处理。
So in some cases, the porous surface of the rumford tile has been painted over to kind of seal off those pores and to make it more reflective of sound. And these days we want our architecture to have a range of reverb. Now one single room or venue can accommodate a lot of different kinds of sounds. And that's possible using not just passive acoustic materials like the one Sabine pioneered, but also active acoustics. one's Sabine pioneered, but also active acoustics. Using microphones and loudspeakers and digital signal processing.
那是梅尔声学的声学工程师梅洛迪·帕克（Melody Parker）。他们有一款名为Constellation的产品。所以Constellation允许你做的是在一个空间中创造多个环境。它基本上允许你完全通过数字方式，通过许多微型扬声器和麦克风组成的系统来操纵房间的声音。麦克风在哪里？
That's Melody Parker, an acoustic engineer at Myersound. And they have this product called Constellation. And so what Constellation allows you to do is to create multiple environments in one space. It basically allows you to manipulate the sound of the room completely digitally, through a system of many tiny speakers and microphones. Where are the microphones?
贯穿整个天花板。它们真的很小。梅洛迪向埃弗里展示了位于伯克利的梅尔声学总部内部的consellation测试室。它看起来像一个小剧院。由于采用了大量的声学填充物，这是一个混响时间很短的房间。但它配备了一个可变的主动声学系统，微型扬声器捕捉声音，扬声器回放这些声音，以模仿不同大小房间的混响。
Throughout the ceiling. They're really small. Melody showed Avery the test room for consolation inside Meyer Sound's headquarters in Berkeley. It looks like a very small theater. It's a room with a low reverb time, thanks to much acoustic padding. But it's outfitted with a variable active acoustic system, where tiny microphones capture the sound, and the speakers play back those sounds to mimic the reverberation in different sized rooms.
我应该演示一下。好的，那我拿。梅洛迪拿出一台iPad并激活了不同的设置，这彻底改变了房间的声学形状。我现在做一个戏剧性的演示。这就是拥有非常长的混响时间时的声音。梅洛迪弹奏了克拉维钟（clave）来演示混响时间。
I should demonstrate. Yeah. Okay, so I'll grab. Melody took out an iPad and activated different settings, which completely changed the sonic shape of the room. I now do a dramatic demonstration. This is what it sounds like with a very long reverberation time. Melody played the clave to demonstrate the reverb time.
这个设置被称为“神圣空间”（Sacred Space），它让这个狭小的房间拥有了大教堂般的声音。在歌曲或播客中听到混响效果是一回事。在现实生活、真实时间的房间里体验混响效果完全是另一回事。回声彻底改变了我对这个空间的感知。然后梅洛迪完全去掉了房间里的混响，顿时感觉令人窒息，就像我被封住了嘴一样。呼吸困难。这些是星座系统（constellation）中最戏剧性的一些设置。
This setting was called Sacred Space, and it gave this tiny room the sound of a cathedral. And it's one thing to hear a reverb effect in a song or a podcast. It's another thing entirely, to experience a reverb effect in a room, in real life, in real time. The echo completely changed my perception of the space. Then melody took the reverb completely out of the room just entirely, and suddenly it felt stifling, like I'd been muzzled or something. It was hard to breathe. And those are some of the most dramatic settings on constellation.
客户可以对房间进行许多微妙的更改。他们有能力改变混响的长度，改变混响的强度或响度，改变混响的强度或响度，甚至改变房间的感知高度和感知宽度。Constellation及其竞争对手的音响系统价格昂贵，所以它们并不十分常见，但它们出现在比你想象的更多的许多地方，比如世界各地的许多大型场馆、教室和办公室。餐馆使用所谓的可变主动声学系统，以便它们可以调整噪声水平，使其保持在令人愉悦的嗡嗡声中，而不管空间里有多少人。这带来的建筑学意义是令人着迷的。当然，建筑师和声学家
There are lots of subtle changes that a client could make to a room. They have the ability to change the length of the reverberation, change the strength or the loudness of the reverberation, change the strength or the loudness of the reverberation, and to even change the perceived height of the room and the perceived width of the room. Constellation in its competitor sound systems are expensive, so they're not common exactly, but they're in a lot more places than you'd think, like a number of big venues all over the world, and classrooms, and offices. Restaurants use so-called variable active acoustics, so they can adjust the noise level to keep it in a pleasant hum, regardless of how many people are in the space. And the architectural implications of this are fascinating. Of course, architects and acousticians
仍然必须关注被动声学和建筑材料，但现在的设计灵活性要大得多。是的，我们实际上有一个有趣的项目正在为一个科技企业进行改造，他们接管了一座老工厂。那是梅尔声学的阿什利·汉森。所以那个空间面临的挑战是，
still have to pay attention to the passive acoustics and the building materials, but there's a lot more design flexibility now. Yeah, we actually have an interesting one that we're working on for a tech business where they took over an old factory. That's Ashley Hansen at Myr Sound again. And so the challenges in that space,
工厂都是砖砌的、外露的、美丽的，而且有着高高的天花板。她说，主动和被动声学系统的结合帮助建筑师重新利用了旧建筑。我们能够将那些绝不会用于某些特定用途的空间，变得非常适合各种不同的活动。这在以前是不会发生的。这座老工厂里的办公空间将是一场混响的噩梦。
it's the factories all brick and exposed and beautiful and have these high ceilings. And she says a combination of active and passive acoustic systems help architects repurpose old buildings. We're able to take spaces that would never be used for certain applications and make them great for all sorts of different events. And that wouldn't happen before. This office space in this old factory would just be a reverberant nightmare.
没有人能够集中精力。他们可能也不会为此买单。像圣托马斯教堂这样的建筑标志着我们通过被动声学控制建筑环境中声音的探索的开始。现在，一百年过去了，凭借先进的主动声学技术，我们可以将声音与空间分离。仓库可以听起来像歌剧院，歌剧院可以听起来像小俱乐部。这只取决于我们想要多少混响。
No one could focus. And they probably wouldn't have purchased it for that. Buildings like St. Thomas Church marked the beginning of our quest to control sound in the built environment through passive acoustics. Now, a hundred years later, with advanced active acoustics, we can separate sound from space. Warehouses can be made to sound like opera houses, and opera houses can sound like small clubs. It's just a matter of how much reverb we want.
在本集中，我们收录了一些来自20世纪20年代和30年代纽约市的真实声音。你可以在汤普森教授与南加州大学合作制作的这个令人难以置信的互动网站上找到它们。它有一张纽约的地图，你可以点击它来查看20年代它的外观和声音。找到它的最简单方法是访问shoutoutthenoise.com。说真的，去看看吧，超级酷。shoutoutthenoise.com。
In this episode we featured some actual sounds from New York City from the 1920s and 1930s. You can find them on this incredible interactive website that Professor Thompson made in collaboration with the University of Southern California. It's got a map of New York and you can click around it to see what it looked like and what it sounded like in the 20s. And the easiest way to find it is to go to shutoutthenoise.com. Seriously, check it out, super cool. Shutoutthenoise.com.
特别感谢本·斯特朗（Ben Strange）、亚历克斯·斯托尔（Alex Stoll）以及梅尔声学的每一个人。本周的《99% Invisible》由埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，拒绝塞思·凯蒂·明格（Seth Katie Mingle）、库尔特·科斯特（Kurt Colestet）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、泰兰·马扎（Terran Mazza）、黛兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 K-A-L-W 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市市中心的 Radio Row 制作。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，以及@节目 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Tumblr 上。但所有 99PI 事物的核心都在 Radio Tapio。
Special thanks to Ben Strange, Alex Stoll, and everyone at Myersound. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffleman, which refused Seth Katie Mingle, Kurt Colestet, Sam Greenspan, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, Delaney Hall, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But the Nexus of all things 99PI is at Radio Tapio.
来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。